[Musique]
le virus a tué tous ceux qui l'ont
contractée alors comment peut-il être
infecté par le virus sans en mourir
[Musique]
c'est comme ça il a besoin d' aide et si
quelque chose tourne mal
tu sais qu'on veuille les uns sur les
autres
il faut commencer à travailler sur le
traitement tout de suite je continue de
croire qu'on peut les sauver
il s'agit d'une maladie grave qui
détruit le système immunitaire
il faut l'arrêter avant qu'ils
apprennent à le contrôler le premier
d'entre vous qui nous la mènera ici sera
libéré on est plus en sécurité
[Musique]
et peut pas contrôler ton frère il est
trop dangereux
[Musique]
et mon devoir de protéger le trafic
n'avait pas peur
[Musique]